ça va faire les abdos
c'est quoi le Pilate c'est quoi c'est ça
là non ça c'est pas depuis là c'est du
pilote
[Applaudissements]
parce que c'est surtout quelqu'un qui
mention
tu me la mets tu me la mets comme ça
sans déconner frère tu vois ça va être
pas mal martien c'est quoi le plus là
le même manucure que pédicure que
Guillaume
c'est plus rapide que les que quand on
fait des machines c'est pas plus rapide
mais c'est sympa pour les femmes parce
que en longueur le parle en longueur
c'est ça parce que sinon ça fait ouais
ça muscle en longueur tout works
est-ce que il y a quelque chose à faire
pour être en forme dès qu'on se réveille
pour bien commencer la journée pour être
en forme déjà bon alors déjà au réveil
il faut toujours penser à s'y hydrater
c'est la première chose à faire c'est
boire de l'eau parce que la nuit on perd
beaucoup d'eau on est complètement
déshydratés
un film
c'est la preuve d'accord d'accord très
bien faut pas péter ça par contre
c'est très sympa
bravo bravo bah très bien mettez-nous
des trucs comme ça et puis nous elle va
continuer à nous parler merci martial
vous êtes un amour c'est donc prof de
théâtre sportif
donc il paraît que le premier réflexe
social le matin c'est faire des
étirements
on va commencer par la posture de
l'enfant donc on s'est réveillé il y en
a mal partout etc donc posture de
l'enfant on vient sur les genoux à
genoux
je t'expliquerai au contraire
et le ventre le plus possible
[Rires]
d'accord très bien
quelque chose qui est basique basique le
matin c'est le chien de tomba le chien
ouais le chien teint mais si vous n'êtes
pas très souple vous pliez le genou
l'important c'est d'avoir le dos droit
d'accord et ça pour moi
toute la journée
ça c'est des choses qu'il faut faire
juste
pour ça
[Applaudissements]
il parait qu'on travaille à une petite
astuce il faut serrer les fesses quand
on est sur son siège toute la journée et
ça permet de contenir les
travailler les muscles c'est ça alors ça
c'est vrai en fait c'est tout simple
vous êtes assis sur le bord de la chaise
droite les sables dont l'intérieur
toujours
[Rires]
[Musique]
musculaire d'ailleurs si vous voyez les
joueurs de football on met un spray
après
parce que c'est idéal pour la cellulite
ça va aider la cellulite pour la
cellulite
et ça va donner un aspect beaucoup plus
lisse
pour la cellulite
la cellulite
mais est-ce que ça marche quand on prend
le matin une douche chaude enfin à notre
convenance et après on finit par du
froid ou est-ce qu'il faut aller
directement froid non on prend la douche
normale et après
tout le monde n'a pas un jacuzzi
après je peux directement quoi
il y a une technique pour ne plus avoir
faim il faut se laver les dents ah oui
alors
il faut boire de l'eau avant de manger
excusez-moi donc là le matin donc on
boit de l'eau après on fait les
étirements à prendre pour une douche
froide tu après on arrive au bureau à
quelle heure
on se réveille tôt
il va se réveiller avant
il parait qu'il faut éviter absolument
le pain
tous les points
sèche le pain arrête le pain
il y a un truc il y a un truc que vous
pouvez faire si vous voulez vraiment
perdre vite sinon mais c'est très dur il
faut éviter de manger tout ce qui
contient des miettes c'est un peu le
biscuits du pain
tout ce qu'il y a des miettes des
gâteaux les chips voilà exactement des
miettes tout ce qui fait des miettes
vous évitez et là c'est pas mal c'est ma
technique on fait ce que tu veux dire
dès que tu vois un truc qui fait des
miettes même si c'est le livre de
loanaque ça
c'est intéressant
alors non non ça veut dire qu'elle le
souffle c'est non trois fois par semaine
minimum aussi
non mais c'est ce que vous qui dites
c'est vous qui le dites
après ça dépend
tout seul
depuis 50 ans ça s'accumule ça
s'accumule
elle risque pas d'avoir une diagonite
et comme ça quand on a beaucoup de poids
à perdre est-ce que c'est vrai qu'il
faut d'abord faire un régime et pas
faire de sport ou est-ce qu'il faut
faire du sport directement quand on a 10
20 30 kilos
moi je pense faut d'abord sécher et
après le sport parce que les deux en
même temps ça va être très dur
après elle dit ce qu'elle veut c'est
elle l'a spécialiste il faut quand même
faire de sport parce que comme on fait
doucement brûle des calories et on
active le métabolisme
en fait ça c'est oui et non qu'on en
fait un sport modéré ça régule la petite
là on a faim et puis toute façon si on a
ça on peut toujours manger Chelsea
la viande rouge tu manges du pain
mais je mange tout ce qui est patate
douce
et c'est très bien patate douce mais bon
patate douce c'est la seule patate qui
est dégueulasse je veux bien frère
tu as l'impression d'avoir un dentier tu
as 40 ans en une bouché arrête un peu
sympa vous aussi alors ils me disent
tous ouais je mange normalement hein je
mange de la patate douce je mange des
épinards et
je connais quoi du soja et des brocolis
frère et après je m'ouvre les veines
tu es tranquille le soir tu veux te
faire un kit tu arrives à regarder mon
assiette comme elle est belle j'ai des
brocolis pas de tête doucement
mais quand tu étais une vie de merde tu
as une vie de merde et tu manges des
pizzas non
[Applaudissements]
couscous
ah tu manges jamais chez les gens quoi
mais non je suis capable de manger tout
le pain de shabbat d'accord
de temps en temps le samedi le week-end
oui mais enfin si on mange tous les
jours de fromage
si on rentre le ventre tout l'été puis
on était
si on va sinon est-ce que comment il
faut de temps pour toi pour par exemple
je vais prendre un
bon lui on le voit pas bien mais torse
nu il est il est dégueulasse
il faut faire des abdos surtout mais
maintenant il est flasque il est flasque
flasque
non mais qu'est-ce que tu en penses
du nutella sur le corps pour pouvoir
passer encore notre étendu
[Rires]
en âge plus c'est difficile aussi de
perdre et de faire des muscles faire ce
sera plus facile ça peut rien dire ça je
te jure moi j'ai vu des mecs je te jure
j'ai vu des gars
on peut tout faire exactement voilà
exactement en compétition bikini je suis
hyper impressionné qui avait fan de
soins entre 60 65 ans
incroyable ils sont mieux que les filles
de 25 ans donc c'est pas vrai ça c'est
pas ah oui j'étais là
c'est des excuses mais oui des excuses
on peut tout faire avec tout le monde on
peut tout faire avec tout le monde moi
je vais éviter parce que la natation
est-ce que c'est c'est mieux on sculpte
plus vite
c'est une sculpture c'est c'est un beau
terreau mais c'est une sculpture plus
bénéfique ou pas bien sûr ça va pas dire
encore sculpté c'est quoi le mieux alors
non le pilater le fitness les machines
encore cardio
tu mets des implants tu ne sais pas
jouer
j'ai un problème en France parce qu'à
chaque fois en compétition on peut voir
le skinny Margarita d'accord
[Rires]
non mais c'est vrai
quel est pour nos téléspectateurs le
meilleur sport pour commencer lorsqu'on
a pas d'activité physique c'est-à-dire
voilà parce qu'à un moment on peut pas
démarrer comme des des balles et au bout
de deux semaines tu vas être tu vas être
tu vas être blessé donc forcément tu te
retrouves comme un con et en fait si tu
vas encore reprendre 10 kg parce que tu
vas être bloqué comme un connard déjà
c'est bien des marchés
au lieu de l'ascenseur
des associations il faut marcher pour
l'instant marcher la majorisme
c'est déjà ça
il faut se progresser regardez tous vous
êtes comme ça
mais mieux comme ça quoi on respire
mieux ça c'est sûr on respire mieux
[Musique]
dites-moi est-ce que vous avez trois
conseils à donner à nos téléspectateurs
pour que ça aille plus vite parce que là
vous avez parlé de 8 mois dans 8 mois
c'est l'hiver on se rend encore on sera
en train de manger des non mais c'est
vrai manger du foie gras comme un coup
il faut vraiment boire beaucoup d'eau on
se rend pas compte mais long c'est la
vie c'est votre meilleur ami non c'est
vrai
une source non mais donc oui boire
beaucoup d'eau et puis essayer de pas
manger trop souple
mais pas trop sucré pas trop salé pas de
produits transformés
c'est pas simple les pâtes des pâtes des
carottes des carottes et des tomates
c'est bon oui plus les légumes
donc on mange que de la merde quoi
très très mauvais
donc vous prenez que les sashimi comme
ça
vous avez le corps de Madame donc
exactement
la différence entre le riz normal et le
riz complet le riz complet frère il est
tout mon frère sur la tête de ma mère
t'as l'impression de manger t'étais pied
mon frère non mais c'est horrible c'est
dégueulasse en fait tout ce qui est
dégueulasse c'est bon pour la santé
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux pas être gros et
heureux
pour nous oui
Delphine toi tu manges tout ce qu'elle
dit
je suis très contente parce qu'en fait
heureuse dans la vie quand même très
heureuse et en fait plus on mange comme
ça plus on prend plaisir à manger comme
ça et on découvre des goûts des saveurs
des épices des choses incroyables et
c'est très très bon et par exemple
pareil pour le sucre moins on mange de
sucre plus après au bout d'un moment
quand on mange un truc trop sucré
carrément ça va nous dégoûter en fait
donc on doit on doit mettre le sucre
alors ça c'est ça c'est vrai ce qu'elle
dit en fait plus on mange du sucre plus
vous voulez de sucre c'est aujourd'hui
je prends ma pain au chocolat il y a des
récidives qui vont rester dans ma langue
puisque on gratte pas la langue
et ça vous donne envie encore plus de
sucre
bon bah merci merci en tout cas tu nous
as pas beaucoup avancé
[Rires]
tu mangeras tu fais du sport et puis tu
regardes comme ça
on le savait on sait très bien que c'est
pas si on mange dans ce coin de pizza et
qu'on Achille dans le canapé en train de
se gratter les glaçons